grüß Gott und herzlich willkommen bei
lessi Kochen mit Joe waschl sie kennen
die sich alle sie wollen daheim was
kochen für Ihre Lieben ganz was feines
und dann stehen wir uns am fadenrotz in
corner fressen wie weil sie wieder mit
bläht worden zum Kochen
einfach einmal drei Gerichte die in der
modernen Küche gerne mal versaut werden
das ist doch zum Beispiel aufgeschmissen
die brotsuppen bestehend aus Wasser am
Brot Zwiebeln und was war sie und da
haben wir noch ein Bauernfrühstück
Kartoffel Eier und was Sie sonst noch
ein Unrat seit Wochen in der Küche
Milch und naja an Zucker der Marina
Gewürz wird das ganze mit Salz und
Pfeffer und dann wundern sie die Deppen
dass der Baum schmeckt schon Friedrich
da habe ich jetzt Abhilfe geschaffen
jetzt gibt es ein neues Produkt aus der
Joe Russel gewürzlinie ist der knobling
oder Doppel cker in der praktischen
Gewürzmühle da drinnen
Knoblauch drinnen naturbelassen ohne
Geschmacksverstärker da brauchen Sie gar
keine Geschmacksverstärker bei der Hause
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Würfel schnell raus ich habe die
Kloschüssel hat noch mehr gerufen
[Gelächter]
Augen gesehen
ja
knoblinger Doppeldecker darf in keiner
Küche fehlen ist schon Dreck fressen
dann wenigstens gut gewürzt nur Gutes
aus dem Hause
[Musik]